I wish there was just more compassion no
we don't want to make something
difficult we just want to be
acknowledged my daughter was a victim
and she's being punished hi my name is
Marissa gold I am a parent I have two
girls ten and thirteen and I'm also a
parenting expert with my own parenting
company Intuit parenting my name is
David Epstein and I'm a pediatric
intensive care physician
I'm Gary sliver I'm an internal medicine
physician I'm Bob Sears I'm a
pediatrician I guess my greatest passion
is just to help encourage full complete
and foreign consent for vaccinations I'm
also Marissa by trade I am a designer I
am also an activist and a mother I'm
Melissa
Floyd and I would consider myself an
informed consent advocate I just want to
make sure this conversation can be open
for people and continue to inform people
and to listen to everyone to understand
why we each come to our opinion on this
the first statement is I am vaccinated
so I actually wasn't fully vaccinated
interestingly I grew up with two parents
that were into alternative medicine so I
was not vaccinated as a child but as I
got older I vaccinated myself well I was
vaccinated as a child but my last
vaccine was about 15 years ago when I
returned to college and I had a severe
reaction and that I became arthritic in
my hands went to many many doctors and
nobody knew what was going on and why I
was happy and just shocked like it
doesn't make sense you're too young to
have arthritis and it wasn't until
having kids and sort of digging into my
own research for them that a lot of
answers started coming up and I think
it's unfortunate that a lot of it is
overlooked for me and I'll continue to
get vaccinated regardless of the risks
because I've seen too many things on the
other side I've seen kids you know come
into the ICU and die from being on
getting the flu I've always felt like
the the risks are far outweighed by the
benefits of getting the protection not
getting vaccinated and dangers other
people
I will acknowledge of course as a
pediatrician I know vaccines work I know
they give you protection they they vary
greatly in what that protection is it's
not like 100% magical shield over you
completely but I do acknowledge there
are some vaccines like the measles
vaccine and the chickenpox vaccine but
honestly if you don't get those vaccines
yeah you do risk catching the disease
and passing it to others it's such a
complicated topic vaccines and you're
starting to get micro with each
individual vaccine and definitely the
question was talking about the big
picture and I think yeah if you get
micro probably some of these vaccines I
think when you're giving kids medication
you have to get micro about it I don't
think it's doing your kids any service
to just say X things are all made the
same and they're all safe and healthy
good for you that everybody's benefiting
from it because that's false
well we studied them before we release
them to the public we study them so we
do know they're safe that's the thing is
we ish you know being an intensive us I
see the worst of the worst and so seeing
the other side of kids who don't get
vaccinated I saw a kid walking in with
meningococcemia which I haven't seen in
decades he had all four limbs cut off
they had to be amputated because it was
all dead tissue you forget how bad
things were before we had vaccines I
didn't step forward for that because I
don't like the assumption that if a
child is unvaccinated somehow they are
of risk to everyone and also knowing
that vaccinated individuals can also be
caring and spreading diseases I think
it's very polarizing to separate the two
as if if you're vaccinated you're
totally fine you're not risking anybody
anything unvaccinated children don't
just have diseases hanging out in their
bodies waiting to unload at any moment
anybody could be spreading diseases
especially things like polio and
pertussis that are not completely
covered by the vaccine I
to keep my child safe I agree I don't
have kids but when I think about it you
know the idea with vaccines is you're
protecting all of us you're protecting
the group you know there's this idea of
herd immunity and so I think that's why
it's really important to talk about
because this is an issue that doesn't
just affect you it affects everyone
around you because there's people that
aren't vaccinated that are sick or have
immune issues or they're too young to
get a vaccine and they count on her
immunity I think most people too like I
started out vaccinating my daughter
because I believed all the same things
that you said it wasn't until she had a
reaction and several reactions that I
actually had to look at it differently
where I I realized by continuing
vaccinating for her that actually would
hurt her and yet everyone wants me to do
it for the population as if I'm supposed
to continue to sacrifice my child for
everyone else well I mean there are
medical exemptions for for vaccines and
if your child has a reaction and then
there's some there's concern I think
that's valid but I think a larger
population is using other justifications
to not get the vaccines you know a
number of families who look into
vaccines they will decide to opt out of
vaccines because they feel they are just
not willing to risk the side effects but
the side effects are the side effects
are like one in a million one in two
million whereas the side effects from
the diseases when I see all these
outbreaks and things like I'm gonna
choose vaccines every time and that's I
think right there is the disservice to
this conversation because it is a risk
benefit analysis and what's unfortunate
is how downplayed those risks are I only
started investigating vaccines because I
ended up with a kid with an autoimmune
disorder so what does that mean and
instead of finding answers I have more
questions the one in a million is not a
real number and so you're more that that
is put out is it so people think that no
well not when you're talking about the
different kind of reactions I think the
number you're referring to is
anaphylactic shock that anaphylactic
shock is of course extremely rare
whereas you when you look at seizures
from the MMR vaccine are one in 3,000
but again is creative ear when we worry
what we worry that you get those on your
side kind of downplay those so my
daughter had seizures seizures for most
people are considered kind of a big deal
you know when it happens to you that
that downplayed element of well that's
not anaphylactic shock it's just a
seizure it is just a seizure but
seizures can be dangerous I don't think
it's an idea of downplay I think it
comes back to what we were saying with
the risk benefit analysis and I think
the data is very clear that the benefits
of giving vaccines by far outweigh the
risks so I don't think it's a question
of downplaying the risks they're there
but we also know that children were
dying and now they're not and yes
there's side effects but they're not as
bad as what we had before vaccines I
don't always trust my doctor's opinion
anytime anyone whether it's a teacher a
friend something I read online my mom
you know my doctor anytime anyone tells
me oh you should do this especially if
it has to do with their health I'm going
to do research and it's I would be
careful about saying it's that I don't
trust my doctor but that has that trust
has been developed over time and so I
would say in the early years when my
children were very young when they would
say this is what we recommend yes of
course there were times where I got a
second opinion or did the research on my
own and asked the questions and I think
that as parents we have to do that
well it's hard to trust someone who sees
your child for 10 minutes twice a year
in the end parents know their children
best and that little office visit where
your pediatrician looks at your child he
does not know your child the way you
know your child so it's really hard for
whatever recommendation he's making to
be really based and into individualized
for your kid so if you were to come to
your doctor and say hey my child's
acting differently after this this well
visit appointment something's wrong you
want them to trust that you have an
established relationship and listen to
you and hear you and understand that as
a mother just because you don't have the
dr in front of your name it doesn't make
your opinion somehow less valuable yeah
I mean I think like anyone doctors are
fallible and they don't know everything
and I think it's very important like
you're mentioning to have a really
strong doctor-patient relationship I
think that's really hard in today's
ten-minute appointment age you know
makes it really difficult but like as a
young doctor I think there's a lot of
distrust when it comes to physician
recommendations it sucks because you
know you spend decades training and
learning and your heart is in this place
where you want to like be of service to
people and then you're not trusted but
you know to answer the question you
shouldn't just blindly trust anyone's
opinion your doctor or anyone i rana CLE
the doctors are the one fit well I trust
my physicians my daughter has epilepsy
and in March she was also diagnosed with
juvenile idiopathic arthritis I went to
the rheumatology
and the rheumatologist said we're gonna
put her on methotrexate and I looked at
her I'm like methotrexate that's a
chemotherapy Kimber therapeutic agent
that you know kids with cancer again and
she's like yes but we use it in a low
dose and it doesn't cause harmful side
effects you have to trust me I said okay
and I trusted her and I am so glad that
I did before all this happened she was a
competitive gymnast and she used to walk
up and down the stairs like she was 90
years old she couldn't hold a pencil in
her hand now she's back on the bars and
back on the on the beam doing things
which my wife and I never thought that
she would do again so yes do I trust my
physicians yes do I question them yes I
will say look can we do this for her can
we do this instead and yes you know I I
can appreciate what you guys have said
as far as people hearing you and I think
that's the biggest problem in medicine
is that time is short clinicians aren't
listening and I think that as as a
pediatrician you know one of the most
important jobs that we have is to listen
to parents and I think that if any
pediatrician isn't doing that they're
not doing their job
I don't like it I don't I want us to be
able to talk I want us to be able to
have relevant and educated conversations
and I think at the core of this
conversation is what is at the core of
humanity and being a parent which is
that we all want to do right by our
children and we want to lead happy
healthy and productive lives yeah I have
no doubts in my mind of how I've come to
my decision making on the subject which
has been tedious and thorough to say the
least I did not expect to go down this
path in my life but I have people who
won't be friends with me who I've had
death threats on social media I might
not even be able to send my kids to
school depending on how legislation
changes because of the way I think it
just it's insane to me how hostile this
has become and it's not doing a service
to research and science moving forward
and just the overall dialogues we have
in our culture whatever the subject what
I think is lacking in this debate or
conversation is really compassion from
the pro vac side or pro mandate side
I'll say the people who refuse to
acknowledge that vaccine reactions are
happening or that the things that
happened to my daughter were connected
because maybe it was just a coincidence
and I just needed something to pin it on
you are socially isolated you can be
isolated by your family isolated by the
medical community isolated by society as
a whole because they assume you're
unintelligent uneducated and irrational
I wish there was just more compassion
that no we don't want to make something
difficult we just want to be
acknowledged my daughter was a victim
and she's being punished what I signed
up for this it was a little bit of
trepidation coming into this because you
do hear things in the media you know
about the people who are anti vaccine
and the way they respond to physicians
and it is a little bit scary you know as
physicians we care about people there is
compassion on on the medical community
side we wouldn't do this if we if we
didn't care but again you know I do have
compassion for the families that have
gone through issues with you know with
vaccines and
I have a great deal compassion for the
families that had children die from
preventable diseases there shouldn't be
any hostility there should be discussion
I mean we can always question things
that's how we of all that's how we get
better if we didn't question anything
we'd be still in the dark ages hey guys
I'm Kendra I'm Erin and we're from
Jubilee media thank you so much for
watching this episode of middle ground
we try to encourage radical empathy in
our work so we're very appreciative that
you took the time to watch one of our
videos make sure you let us know what
you think in the comments below also
make sure to subscribe follow us on
Instagram and we'll see you next time